[Musik]
mit dem europäischen verteidigung so hat
die europäische kommission die förderung
von gemeinsamen grenze überschreiten
forschungs und entwicklungsprojekten
vorgeschlagen
dazu sind im nächsten finanzrahmen 13
milliarden euro vorgesehen und dienen
insbesondere für die entwicklung von
gemeinsamen europäischen fähigkeiten
dies ist ein völlig neuer ansatz der
europäischen union bereitet historisch
gesehen erstmals eine förderung von
verteidigungs bereichen aus dem
gemeinsamen eu haushalt
diese konferenz meine sehr geehrten
damen und herren bietet eine einmalige
chance das potenzial und die
möglichkeiten des europäischen
verteidigungsfonds in einem breiten
rahmen zu erörtern und zu einer
erfolgreichen implementierung des
europäischen verteidigungsfonds im
interesse der europäischen union der
mitgliedstaaten aber damit auch der
europäischen bevölkerung entsprechend
auch beizutragen zu sehen
[Musik]